[Music]
well as we're talking coronavirus
Walmart has a new like they had like
this new clinic that they have been
implementing as a tester in Georgia
called Walmart health where they are now
providing lab work x-rays dental care
you can get routine checkups
for and then you could do like ongoing
treatment of chronic diseases like
diabetes and heart disease
they even do behavioral behavioral
health counseling and I am hearing exams
all this do they do blood hormonal tests
I don't know cuz the minute someone
tells me I've below-average testosterone
for my jump on steroids I can we you
could get your assess for like 200 bucks
I got a buddy who does HGH and he
[ __ ] loves it
what's HGH human growth hormone oh you
inject it into your nuts and [ __ ]
Richard dick ha you want to eat a pizza
and have a six-pack do you know why Brad
you know why Brad Pitt stayed hot for so
[ __ ] cuz of HGH HGH really lot of
celebs a lot of celebs are on just a
little bit just a little bit of stuff
well they all it's kind of precursors to
testosterone there's different ways of
getting there but you have a little bit
more testosterone have a little bit more
muscle mass of a less fat and a little
bit more vitality really why do people
make it seem like it's so bad
well because people like the guys that
use it they go which it's a good dish
then their hair falls out and then
they're like yeah their heart gets all
babe
even though I think it makes sports way
more entertaining yeah [ __ ] early
2000 Sammy Sosa never I don't care for
steroids it's fun to watch they're both
doing steroids that was the competition
was that MMA was like that they were all
[ __ ] jack monsters in a cage and
you're like yeah I know
so is HGH legal if your doctor
prescribes it that's the thing they
don't take it legally a lot of these
people a lot that's what most celebs
don't there's ways of cheating it so
order
fast ways of cheating is if you fast for
24 hours and then you get sleep-deprived
for 3 hour for 3 days then you naturally
drop your testosterone so when you go
get checked they go all you have low
blood testosterone so a doctor will loop
holes around it of getting it legally
but then the people there's people that
actually have low testosterone that just
need it like if like just by sitting
here they their muscles start getting
weaker and their phones start getting
brittle so they need the actual
injection to like move around so there's
actual cases that you do need it but if
I can get my blood test the minute the
minute it goes i'ma go ha ha and take it
in old people take it yeah hmm dude my
buddy my buddy was taking it and he
loved it cuz he has the same hair thing
as me and his hair was growing back but
then he told me he's lost his sex drive
and I was like I'm not how are the bball
with a boner
but right you could take viagra sure but
if you lose your desire to have sex then
why you're not gonna think up and buy a
really horny yeah same that's you might
be doing it wrong cuz most people I know
that take it they're hornier well so
that could happen to it just depends on
who you are and how your physiology
isn't very true I think it's reversible
but it was just it was just depressing
for a little while to lose I don't know
if it could be reversed
why okay once you're once you are not
horny anymore you cannot get horny
anyway we were talking about Walmart
healthcare the fact that Walmart is now
trying to get into the healthcare I
thought I get to steroids no you how are
we gonna get it so that you could be at
home getting diagnosed by a doctor
you got home blood test now yeah home
dog it's called heal
yeah but full like full diagnosis for
all kind of [ __ ] yeah yeah well no right
so what I'm saying see that's what I'm
saying so some kind of a home thing work
oh really to a machine and AI is [ __ ]
telling you what that like we're only a
couple years away from this hell yeah
we're where you won't have to go to a
hospital
cuz if you think about it what do they
do they check your temperature they
check your piss they check your blood
they check your breathing so why can't
an AI do that they're not
do it because to infect more people
equals more money but there's companies
working on right now but that one and
don't want to do it there I'm home test
kits though for a lot of [ __ ]
sure but I'm talking about the full
gamut right though like like yeah you
even even home test for pregnancy for
example but that's not what I'm getting
at it's like people like there was a
woman who brought coronavirus into a
school system because she worked at a
hospital and was involved with somebody
like growing a virus so they sneeze on
her arm and then [ __ ] [ __ ] got Crona
yeah that was in California so she's in
quarantine now but that's the whole
point right is if she was not if the
karana person didn't have to go to the
hospital to get diagnosed would have
been sick no I like that
good job thank you I didn't mean to and
I wish I could take it back
drive-through coronavirus check things
drive-through they're doing a drive
McDonald's yeah wait that's on your side
[Laughter]
on the side yes they put your dick okay
thank you
let's wind up what you do the first week
I mean I think that's cool yeah I mean
it's cool cuz they're saying that the
bill for an annual checkup for an adult
is $30 without insurance Wow and an eye
exam is $45 and a dental exam costs $25
therapy sessions are 60 bucks Wow so
don't be too yeah I mean that's what I
supposed Walmart therapy though that's
what a lot of people are saying we're
not a lot but even the people involved
they don't trust themselves like well my
dad's
what was it a dentist or I forgot what
it was let's just say that just like
yeah my dad's a dentist so I don't know
like I can't really imagine him being a
dentist at Walmart [ __ ] weird
he works at Walmart if you think part of
the thing what if you can get out of low
prices yeah what if you're at Walmart
and you're buying sugar cookies and I'm
like hey we're having a rollback right
now on therapy
am i oh that's actually very goal
because they're losing a lot with Amazon
like online retailers and the Giants
they're trying to get people to walk in
and so for help you have to walk in and
you could get the soda there get
diabetes and on the way out you can cure
your diagram that doesn't sound safe
like is it all on the same is it like oh
my god it's like I feel like it's in the
back where the lenses are kaiser but you
can buy like lettuce we have a separate
entrance way that entrance attached to
the walmart and then this is what the
new one looks like this is actually Wow
I mean that looks good it's kind of like
how you can go to Rite Aid and you know
buy your [ __ ] chips and then there's
a pharmacy in the back yeah all they do
is like flu shots or like blood pressure
check whatever this is like full-on
it is better they close the thrifty name
but they kept the ice cream huh branding
dude branding right ain't ice cream
doesn't sound good doesn't know it
sounds like Mike's and ate ice cream I
am somebody who used to not have
insurance right and would just go to
like I don't know clinics when I needed
a checkup or whatever this would have
been really cool yeah that looks nice to
even mean that I do have insurance
it's so [ __ ] expensive they're saying
that this is good for people who like
who have insanely high deductibles that
they just those two crazy like me like
I'm part of this what's a hard enough my
insurance I have to pay so a high
deductible as far as I understand it is
like for example for our family I think
it's like twelve thousand dollars or
something which means we have to keep
paying for whatever medical expenses we
need until we reach the twelve thousand
dollars that's when insurance will kick
in and then so yeah so my old man he has
he's type two diabetic and so when he
goes to get his prescriptions filled he
uses Walmart because they have way cheap
generics like compared to a lot of
places so if this is kind of like that
that's that's pretty cool
my dad's been getting drugs illegally
sent from Canada this way cheaper that
way hey
sent I got accutane sent to me from like
[ __ ] India or here's the capsule way
cheaper is so much cheaper it was great
what does a queue team do
hey you Tina dries your skin out big
time so that you can get rid of acne
that it wasn't all like [ __ ] it's
actually way cool it's actually the
coolest [ __ ] medication I've ever
taken in my life like it cleared up your
skin like what does a skin like nothing
else ever has in my life yeah I'd swear
once you stop it's gonna come back ten
times worse so we know it doesn't it can
come back look so I had to do it four
times so like I did it the first time it
came back three years later I did the
second time it came back three years
later third time same thing and then the
fourth time I was thirty and it just
dimmer came back why don't people just
focus on Chi energy Oh like that II just
busting that Chi energy to cure
everything
oh you bust it oh that that's the way I
don't trust as much because you don't
have to pay for it Oh some effect I'm
gonna get real good yeah I trust him
that chia energy nice Hey sexual healing
sound sexual healing whoa you know and
and just there's nothing a [ __ ] can
fix they should prescribe those at
Walmart would that be great if your
doctors like payment you know get blown
tonight give this to your wife yeah you
get you get government hand jobs in
Japan oh if you're like yeah the table
I've seen that stuff about that it's a
government it's a government-funded time
I think that's like good that they do
that it might be worth it it for in
solid just breaking a lay so you'll be
part of that problem
[ __ ] it break my leg okay give me hand
jobs for life no I can't just give it to
all like they're not to these people no
but it's more like you know people that
are like mentally disabled and maybe
they can't we can't jack off jack off
yeah yeah yeah it's like a human need
kai I mean just if I could say it
insurance provider
it is but I'm just like trying to get
into the minds of like I mean especially
for dudes like we get physically like I
don't know like if you don't jizz after
a week it gets uncomfortable you start
to feel sad you feel like what's the
point of life you so yelling at the TV
and stuff and juicing is good for your
prostate oh yeah prostate yeah yeah she
is so good to jerk off it's like really
important there's no healthier man in
this movie I have bronchitis for over a
month prostate is working condition oh
yes pretty soon we might see Walmart
health popping up everywhere dude
Walmart health handjobs bring it on old
ladies the greeters imagine when Costco
gives you the hand jobs and it's like 10
hands at once for half the price and you
get a sample yeah oh you like two hands
on your balls in it and then they're
giving you samples of tuna on crackers
that the same the lines are to be so
long though
oh yeah like to get a hand job sample
the hand job plate should be inside the
store not outside where everyone can go
there in the store so you got to use
your card so that the client gets kind
of have like a members-only thing
people's me kid I know I hate it but at
least it's better than the outside one
[Music]